-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated
and Golden Globe-winning actor
you know from his work
on "House, M.D.," "Veep,"
and "The Night Manager."
He stars in the miniseries
"Roadkill,"
which airs its fourth and fina
episode Sunday night
on Masterpiece on PBS.
Let's take a look.
-Let me tell you,
there is a reason
why this country has never moved
into the 21st century,
and it's called
the civil service.
-I am aware of your view.
You've made that plain.
-Any time any minister
comes into office
with any trace of passion
or a serious idea for change
there you are in the best
traditions of your calling
ready to throw a wet blanket
over anything that might improve
people's lives.
Restore the missing clause
to the bill.
That's an order.
Is there anything else?
-Please welcome to the sho
Hugh Laurie!
How are you, Hugh?
-I'm very well, thank you, Seth.
Thank you. Ha, ha, ha.
Ha, ha. Thank you.
-I'm so happy to see you.
This is your first time
on this show.
And we've crossed paths before
but, you know, it's a deligh
to lay eyes on you again.
-Crossed paths?
I think it was a little more
than that in my memory.
I feel --
Well, it was a momentous event
in my life.
-Well, you hosted --
You hosted SNL.
-I did.
-You were hosting it
because of "House."
I knew you as --
from "Blackadder."
I knew you from
"A Bit of Fry & Laurie."
I knew you from my favorit
episode of "The Young Ones."
I knew you as a comedy person.
I was surprised to hear you were
nervous about hosting SNL.
-I was -- That was
the single most terrifying thing
I have ever done, and I have
jumped out of an airplane.
And this was considerably worse,
considerably worse.
Although when I jumped
out of an airplane,
I had an instructor
tied to my back.
And in the case of SNL, you were
that instructor tied to my bac
and you guided me...
-[ Laughs ] That's so --
-...with a gentle
and loving hand,
and I will forever
be in your debt.
I'm not going to repay the debt,
but I am --
Thank you for that.
-It's just nice
that you acknowledge
there is a debt.
Whether it's repaid or not
it's just nice to know.
-Yeah, that's the importan
thing.
-This show, I want to say
about "Roadkill,"
this is exactly what I wanted.
It is my favorite kind of show
It is a PBS Masterpiece
British political intrigue
It's a limited miniseries.
It ticks every box for me.
How did you get involved,
and what drew you to it?
-Well, I was drawn to it
by the name on the title page.
It was written by David Hare
who is a very respected --
I would say even revered
playwright in this country
and in yours, too.
So that piqued my interest
And I thought
it was an interesting notion
to examine the whole idea
of political shame,
the fact that shame and disgrace
in the public sphere,
in the political sphere,
has just, sort of, vanished.
Weirdly, it's been
sort of replaced
by shame in the private sphere
or the sphere
of the private citizen.
But politicians now have
a completely different approach,
completely different
relationship
with their constituency.
And I thought that was
particularly interesting
to examine it from the sort of
right-wing perspective.
There's been so much written
about the left.
But the right wing
generally goes un-remarked on.
We just assume they make
the trains run on time
and nothing else.
But of course, they are capabl
of being every bit
as ideological,
if not more so, than the left.
-It is fun to watch a show
that is both about politic
and about bad behavior
in politics
that isn't tied directly t
the moment we're living through.
I mean, a lot of it overlaps
and you can certainly see,
certainly when we
talk about shame
and being able to escape..
-Right.
-...being shamed.
But it must be fun to play
a sort of charismatic politician
who is ultimately trying
to get away with stuff.
-Well, if it says charismati
in the character description
where are they gonna go,
you know?
I mean, how many --
Yeah, it was.
But, as you say,
it was very peculiar.
It seems peculiar to me no
looking back.
We started it just over --
about a year ago.
And I think there's
just one mention of Brexit
no mention of the pandemic
even though it was kind of
on the horizon.
And it seems
so distant now to me.
It seems almost quaint,
like we're doing
something about Tudor England.
It's -- The world has change
out of all recognition
in 12 months.
And I would like to offer it
as a -- as a parallel universe
where none of the characters
are drawn from
contemporary politics.
It's a story
set in a parallel universe
and I'm a parallel person,
which, actually --
-I think we need
more parallel universes.
We need to take just a light
break from this universe.
-That's exactly right.
-But it is funny
how you consume stuff that was
made right before the pandemic
For example, there's a priso
riot in the first episode.
-Right.
-And I was watching it thinking,
"No one's wearing a mask.
Guys, you can't prison rio
without your masks."
-If you're going to riot,
please throw chairs.
Don't punch.
Throw chairs
from at least six feet.
-You can throw a chair
from six feet away.
They're not heavy chairs.
-If you can't, you can't riot.
It's that simple. Yeah.
-You -- You went to university
with Emma Thompson,
with Stephen Fry,
and you had, at the time,
a very famous revue, I guess
Is that what you'd would cal
the Footlights?
-Yes, it is,
with a U-E at the end.
-Of course, yes.
-It's sort of old --
It's almost sort of
vaudeville thing, really,
kind of sketches and songs
and monologues and --
Well, I mean,
you did much the same.
You did exactly the same,
but more of it and better, Seth.
-I mean, certainly
I was doing stuff like tha
when I was in college, but you
guys were doing it in college,
and it became sort of
a bit of a phenomenon.
That must've been --
Did you think at the time --
Were you aware of how well
it was going for you?
-I was --
I knew it was pretty good.
I was proud of it.
I've spent so much of my lif
in a position of abject shame,
but this is one of those moments
where I actually felt quit
proud of what we were doing.
And I think we all felt
we were onto something good.
But at that point, I was 21.
I had no idea
about doing this for a living.
And, I mean,
it just didn't occur to anybod
to do such a thing.
It was just --
It was out of anybody's kent
until a man turned up
with a big cigar
and said "I'm an agent. Do you
want to do this for a living?"
And I, you know --
"Well, I'll give it a go,"
and here I am.
-I think one of the first time
an American audience, obviously,
got to know you
was from "House, M.D."
Your father was a doctor,
and your son is
in medical school, correct
-I am proud to say
that I am the ham in
the sandwich of genuine doctors.
Yes, my father,
who I absolutely worshipped,
was a general practitioner
and my son is now
a junior doctor.
He's just had
a pretty hairy four months
dealing with COVID in the E.R.
But he's now just sort of
come out of that
and back on his rotation.
And, at the moment, he's o
psychiatry and rather loving it.
And I'm a bit nervous about it
I just don't know
that one ought to have a child
who's a psychiatrist.
I just find it
slightly unnerving.
I feel there may be judgment
-Right, of course.
It is interesting to me
that your son became a doctor.
You are obviously an actor
You have a piano
behind you, I see.
-Oh. Oh, that.
-Your children
were musical, right?
[ Laughs ]
-Uh, yes, they are.
Yeah, absolutely.
Oddly enough, I think there is
--
It seems to me that doctor
are above-averagely medical.
First of all, actually,
they're above-averagely funny.
I find doctors funny.
They tend to be quite --
You know, there's a hint of th
performer in a lot of doctors,
but they also seem to be
very musical.
And they are --
Yes, my kids are musical.
We actually had a band
when they were teenagers.
We would perform
as the Von Crap family.
-[ Laughs ]
-And, yes, we lived out
the title,
and we did sort of wedding
and bar mitzvahs.
-[ Laughs ]
-Very, very unsuccessfully
but memorably, memorably for me.
-I hope no one ever
recognizes your son,
once he's a full doctor,
as being one of the member
of the Von Crap family.
I would have less confidence
going into surgery.
-No. Yeah, "Wait a minute.
Get away from me."
Yeah, no,
that would be a problem.
No, I think he could
live that down.
I think he could
probably live that down.
-I -- It's always so wonderful
to see you.
I do have to tell you,
I mentioned to my mom
that you were going to be
on the show tonight,
and she said, "Please say hell
to Bertie Wooster for me."
And I just wanted you to kno
that all these years later
that's the only thing
that ever mattered to her.
-I would say -- To your mother
I would say "What ho?"
-"What ho?" is a perfect -
perfect response.
Thank you so much for bein
here.
The finale of "Roadkill"
airs Sunday night
on Masterpiece on PBS.